bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france paris temporis donc finalement
sur le retrait des soldats français
engagés au sahel il avait pourtant été
envisagé il ya encore quelques semaines
d'amorcer un retrait des troupes débute
dès ce début d'année 2021
qu'est ce qui selon vous a fait
infléchir la position d' emmanuel macron
mais je crois qu'en réalité la décision
que madame lacroix prise est frappé au
coin du pragmatisme et n'est pas on
n'est pas véritablement une surprise
contrairement à ceux qui anticipent et
déjà un retrait en fait ce qui se passe
c'est condamnant le réajustement le
sursaut stratégique elle militaires
réalisées à la suite du sommet de paul
il ya un an a montré que ce sera ce
sursaut fonctionner pour faire très
court et rapide
on a décidé de concentrer des troupes
plutôt là ou à l'urgence le commander à
savoir contre le gs qui est la franchise
de dèche au sel donc dans cette région
frontalière du mali du burkina et du
niger on a également accru le travail de
partenariat avec les forces israéliennes
sur le terrain dans les pc et on a
également on a également concentrés
voilà sérieux de l'ensemble de ses
moyens dans dans ce dans ce cadre là est
en réalité ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne pourquoi parce que les forces
françaises sont imbriqués de plus en
plus avec nos partenaires sahélien je
vous rappelle que l'objectif en fait
stratégique c'est de mettre à distance à
m faire en sorte que les les forces
aliens puisse traiter à leur tour la
menace et ça fonctionne donc le
président macron dit on continue comme
ça pour l'instant et on se donne
quelques mois pour accroître la montée
en puissance et ses liens il a parlé de
renforts importants 1200 hommes d'un
bataillon tchadien qui va franchir la
frontière pour épauler barkan et les
autres ses liens au mali et au burkina
faso il a également parlé à l'ouest du
côté dans le centre du mali d'un renfort
apporté par les soldats
britannien le chef de l'état qui a aussi
promis une action renforcée pour essayer
d'aller décapiter les organisations
terroristes se sont celles où est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois des opérations militaires
d'envergure alors le problème des mails
macro et des militaires français en
général finalement c'est de ne pas être
accusée de néo-colonialisme de ne pas
être accusé d'ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures et également de
répondre à une certaine forme
d'impatience de notre opinion publique
le millions +8 français je vous rappelle
que le président bacrot voit se dessiner
à grands pas maintenant l'échéance 2022
le problème en fait il est là c'est
qu'il faut pouvoir remettre sur la table
des résultats sans être accusé à
l'extérieur d'ingérence et donc le
président maquereau et le problème de la
france c'est de 10 de faire un distinguo
entre ceux qui sont qu'il qu'on appelle
les djihadistes internationaliste ceux
qui ont un calendrier internationaliste
de l'est les services de renseignements
vous l'expliquer il ya quelques semaines
que rihanna galy et c'est et ses grands
lieutenants étaient les suppôts de ben
laden et en cela il voulait essaimé en
afrique de l'ouest et ils voulaient
semer la terreur en occident ça c'est
une chose et ils veulent d'autre part
pouvoir séparer ces gens-là de tous les
comment dirais-je les revendications qui
s'agrège ponctuellement à ces gens là
les gens qui sont qui se battent pour
des problèmes ethniques pour des
problèmes sociaux pour les problèmes
économiques et tout le pari des manuels
macro et d'essai liens dans les mois qui
viennent c'est de pouvoir continuer à
traiter cette haute hiérarchie dialyse
pour casser la hiérarchie et les et les
généraux et djihadistes et en essayant
en même temps que les états sahéliens
puisse trouver des voies de travail et
de négociations avec des gens qu'on ne
considère pas comme des djihadistes
internationaliste 1 décidément une
position d'équilibré
si on vous comprend bien emmanuel macron
également exhorté les dirigeants des
cinq pays qui représente le g5 sahel
niger le tchad la mauritanie et le
burkina faso il les exhorte au sursaut
politique
il dit aussi souhaiter travailler avec
nos partenaires pour une évolution de
notre présence je le cite qu'est ce que
cela sous-entend alors ça c'est le
troisième volet que vous avez tout à
fait très bien résumé la cg je dirais
que c'est le pari macro nhien c'est un
pari très ambitieux c'est à dire que en
fait jusqu'à présent
rappelez vous en 2013 françois hollande
avait dit ok l'armée française
intervient au mali et puis les maliens
continuerons à gérer leur politique on a
bien vu que c'était si ça n'a pas
fonctionné du tout à telle enseigne que
ce sont les maliens eux mêmes qui ont
pris l'affairé en main les militaires
maliens cet été ont débarqué le
président et bk est avancé aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron fait le pari que les
états vont entrer dans une deuxième
phase qu'ils seront capables cette fois
ce qu'on attend depuis huit ans dès que
la situation aucun état une zone de
territoire sera libéré que l'état malien
reviennent il dit qu'il faut faire
revenir des forces de sécurité
intérieure de la justice et l'éducation
les écoles pour occuper à nouveau le
terrain ça c'est le 3e c'est le
troisième le troisième volet des accords
de n'djamena et c'est le pari le plus
ambitieux c'est évidemment ce qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire depuis huit ans
merci beaucoup pour votre regard
mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
de la défense